foreign
Intelligence on a computer
this has been the holy grail for
artificial intelligence for quite some
time
but how do we get there
so we view ourselves as highly
intelligent beings so it's logical to
study our own brains the substrate of
our cognition for creating artificial
intelligence
imagine if we could replicate how our
own brains work on a computer
but now consider the journey that would
be required
the human brain contains 86 billion
neurons
each is constantly communicating with
thousands of others and each has
individual characteristics of its own
capturing the human brain on a computer
May simply be too big and too complex a
problem to tackle with the technology
and the knowledge that we have today
I believe that we can capture a brain on
a computer but we have to start smaller
much smaller
these insects have three of the most
fascinating brains in the world to me
while they do not possess human level
intelligence each is remarkable at a
particular task
think of them as highly trained
specialists
African dung beetles are really good at
rolling large balls in straight lines
now if you've ever made a snowman you
know that rolling a large ball is not
easy
now a picture trying to make that
Snowman when the ball of snow is as big
as you are and you're standing on your
head
Sahara desertance
our navigation specialists
they might have to wander a considerable
distance to forage for food but once
they do find sustenance they know how to
calculate the straightest path home
and the dragonfly is a hunting
specialist
in the wild dragonflies capture
approximately 95 percent of the prey
they choose to go after
these insects are so good at their
Specialties that neuroscientists such as
myself study them as model systems
understand how animal nervous systems
solve particular problems
and in my own research I study brains to
bring these Solutions the best that
biology has to offer to computers so
consider the dragonfly brain
it has only on the order of one million
neurons
now it's still not easy to unravel a
circuit of even 1 million neurons but
given the choice between trying to tease
apart the one million neuron brain
versus the 86 billion neuron brain which
would you choose to try first
when studying these smaller insect
brains the immediate goal is not human
intelligence
we study these brains for what the
insects do well
and in the case of the dragonfly that's
interception
so when dragonflies are hunting they do
more than just fly straight at the prey
they fly in such a way that they will
intercept it they aim for where the prey
is going to be much like a soccer player
running to intercept a pass
to do this correctly dragonflies need to
perform what is known as a coordinate
transformation going from the eyes form
of reference or what the dragonfly sees
to the body's frame of reference or how
the dragonfly needs to turn its body to
intercept
coordinate Transformations are a basic
calculation that animals need to perform
to interact with the world
we do them instinctively every time we
reach for something
when I reach for an object straight in
front of me
my arm takes a very different trajectory
than if I turn my head look at that same
object when it is off to one side and
reach for it there
in both cases my eyes see the same image
of that object but my brain is sending
my arm on a very different trajectory
based on the position of my neck
and dragonflies are fast
this means they calculate fast
the latency or the time it takes for a
dragonfly to respond once it sees the
prey turn is about 50 milliseconds
this latency is remarkable
for one thing it's only half the time of
a human eye blink
but for another thing it suggests that
dragonflies capture how to intercept in
only
relatively or surprisingly few
computational steps
so in the brain a computational step is
a single neuron or a layer of neurons
working in parallel
it takes a single neuron about 10
milliseconds to add up all its inputs
and respond
the 50 millisecond response time means
that once the dragonfly sees its prey
turn
there's only time for maybe four of
these computational steps or four layers
of neurons working in sequence one after
the other to calculate how the dragonfly
needs to turn
in other words if I want to study how
the dragonfly does coordinate
transformations
the neural circuit that I need to
understand the neural circuit that I
need to study can have at most four
layers of neurons
each layer may have many neurons but
this is a small neural circuit
small enough that we can identify it and
study it with the tools that are
available today
and this is what I'm trying to do
I have built a model of what I believe
is the neural circuit that calculates
how the dragonfly should turn
and here's the cool results in the model
dragonflies do coordinate
transformations in only one
computational step
one layer of neurons
this is something we can test and
understand
in a computer simulation I can predict
the activities of individual neurons
while the dragonfly is hunting
for example here I am predicting the
action potentials or the spikes that are
fired by one of these neurons when the
dragonfly sees the prey move
to test the model my collaborators and I
are now comparing these predicted neural
responses with responses of neurons
recorded in living dragonfly brains
these are ongoing experiments in which
we put living dragonflies in virtual
reality
now it's not practical to put VR goggles
on a dragonfly
so instead we Show movies of moving
targets to the dragonfly
while an electrode records activity
patterns of individual neurons in the
brain
yeah he likes the movies
if the responses that we record in the
brain match those predicted by the model
we will have identified which neurons
are responsible for coordinate
transformations
The Next Step will be to understand the
specifics of how these neurons work
together to do the calculation but this
is how we begin to understand how brains
do basic or primitive calculations
calculations that I regard as building
blocks for more complex functions not
only for interception but also for
cognition
the way that these neurons compute may
be different from anything that exists
on a computer today
and the goal of this work is to do more
than just write code that replicates the
activity patterns of neurons we aim to
build a computer chip that not only does
the same things as biological brains but
does them in the same way as biological
brains
this could lead to drones
driven by computers the same size as the
dragonfly's brain that captures some
targets and avoid others
personally I'm hoping for a small army
of these to defend my backyard from
mosquitoes in the summer
the GPS on your phone could be replaced
by a new navigation device based on dung
beetles or ants that could guide you to
the straight or the easy path home
and what would the power requirements of
these devices be like
as small as it is or sorry as large as
it is the human brain is estimated to
have the same power requirements as a 20
watt light bulb imagine if all brain
inspired computers had the same
extremely low power requirements
your smartphone or your smart watch
probably needs charging every day your
new brain inspired device might only
need charging every few months or maybe
even every few years
the famous physicist Richard Feynman
once said what I cannot create I do not
understand
what I see in insect nervous systems is
an opportunity to understand brains
through the creation of computers that
work as brains do
and creation of these computers will not
just be for knowledge there's potential
for real impact on your devices your
vehicles maybe even artificial
intelligences
so next time you see an insect
consider that these tiny brains can lead
to remarkable computers
and think of the potential that they
offer us for the future
thank you
[Applause]